en el primer vídeo dónde introdujimos la
idea de difusión y gradiente de
concentración
teníamos un contenedor con un solo tipo
de partículas de hecho eran partículas
moradas como estas que tengo aquí y en
nuestro escenario inicial tenemos mayor
concentración de las partículas moradas
en el lado izquierdo que en el lado
derecho si vemos su gradiente de
concentración notaremos que va de una
concentración alta del lado izquierdo a
una concentración baja del lado derecho
de una concentración alta del lado
izquierdo a una concentración baja del
lado derecho y de hecho vimos que
pasaban como tienes más de estas
partículas justo aquí en el lado
izquierdo y todas se están moviendo de
manera aleatoria en distintas
direcciones entonces tienes mayor
probabilidad de que las cosas se muevan
de la izquierda a la derecha que de la
derecha a la izquierda ojo también
tendrás cosas que se mueven de derecha a
izquierda pero tendrás mayor
probabilidad de que se muevan de
izquierda
si dejas pasar un tiempo entonces se
dispersaran más uniformemente a lo largo
del contenedor como este otro escenario
se está moviendo a favor del gradiente
para hacer las cosas más uniformes ahora
lo que es interesante en este diagrama
es que introduje una segunda partícula
estas partículas grandes y amarillas que
tenemos aquí y vemos que su la diente de
concentración va en dirección contraria
entonces tenemos aquí una baja
concentración de hecho no tenemos
partículas amarillas justo aquí entonces
tenemos una concentración muy baja y
aquí tenemos una concentración muy alta
del lado derecho entonces su gradiente
de concentración va a ir de derecha a
izquierda y todo el punto de este vídeo
es mostrar que cada partícula se mueve a
favor de su gran diente único de
concentración asumiendo que bueno no
está bloqueado el paso se moverá a favor
de su gran diente único de concentración
independientemente
que hagan las otras partículas vemos que
las partículas amarillas se moverán de
la concentración alta a la concentración
baja se van a mover mientras que las
partículas moradas se van a mover de
izquierda a derecha se van a difundir de
izquierda a derecha y otra vez no hay
magia kim no es que esta molécula de
aquí haya dicho hey aquí veo siete de
mis amigos y se están abarrotando los
veo
soy claustrofóbico y mejor déjenme
moverme al lado izquierdo no eso no es
lo que está sucediendo estas partículas
solo se están moviendo aleatoriamente y
cuando están en su posición inicial es
decir cuando están exactamente así
no existe probabilidad de que las
partículas de amarillo se muevan de
izquierda a derecha porque bueno no hay
partículas aquí mientras que del otro
lado existe la probabilidad de que
algunas de estas partículas del lado
derecho en un cierto tiempo dado se
puedan mover de la derecha a la
izquierda estas partículas de amarillo y
se mantendrán haciendo esto hasta que se
llegue
una configuración estable donde ahora
existe la misma probabilidad de que las
cosas se muevan de izquierda a derecha
que de derecha a izquierda y esto es
cierto para cada una de las partículas
entonces en conclusión
seguramente escucharás en una clase de
biología o de química que las cosas se
mueven a favor del gradiente de
concentración como puedes ver aquí el
gradiente de concentración de las
partículas de amarillo va en dirección
contraria al gradiente de concentración
de las partículas de morado pero no hay
ninguna magia en esto solo tienes que
imaginar un montón de cosas moviéndose
en un montón de direcciones y luego qué
es lo que pasaría de manera natural
bueno naturalmente hay mayor
probabilidad de que se muevan de una
concentración alta a una concentración
baja que de la concentración baja a la
alta